family is also important to Jason
Bateman and Laura Linney and their
Netflix drama Ozark but so is money
laundering and murder only Brooke
Anderson was on the Atlanta set for all
the behind the scenes action you know
here you see all these some of these
people working over here so so Malayalee
to be noisy we're pretending to be
driving down the road here this is how
the magic happens this is the way you do
it nowadays Jason would know season 1 he
directed four episodes of the Netflix
thriller and for season 2 he's back in
the director's chair for two more the
crew we all love it with Jason directs
me it's sort of the sweetest and the
most satisfying when when he's really
the one Colin Johnson a businessman in
Ozark Jason plays Marty a man who
secretly moves his family to Missouri to
launder money for a drug cartel laura is
his wife Wendy your character keeps
secrets Marty keeps secrets to
personalize life have you killed other
people kill PK guys that's it please to
school learning and one thing we've
learned is no one is safe on the show 14
characters were killed off last season
and the cast says fans can expect even
more and then yeah that's not that's the
one thing that's really that's not some
really good actors have left our show
this year because their characters are
in a bad bad place at a bad time
guest stars maybe your friend Jennifer
Aniston yeah why that would be
interesting wouldn't it I planted a seed
there I never know what's gonna happen
in the others
[Music]